warning the following contains spoilers
for seasons one through three for a
spoiler free version click here just be
sure to come back and watch the real
version when you're all caught up worse
from fictions most notorious serial
killer comes the TV adaptation of the
medieval encyclopedia / Dungeon Master's
guide / porno that is Game of Thrones
don't don't don't - da da da da da song
school get ready for the show that has
viewers on the edge of their seats
wondering what will happen next and as
people who've read the books acting all
smug as they already know it's the
abusive show you keep watching no matter
how many times it hurt you full of
disturbing imagery like incest
beheadings attempted child murder more
incest and that's just the first episode
I've travelled to Westeros a place where
everything is the thing watch as
everyone fights to sit in the world's
most uncomfortable chair while
completely ignoring an invasion of AI
selfies that threatens to kill them all
seriously someone should really get on
that meet unforgettable heroes who were
still alive at the time he wrote this on
a stray there Jon Snow a Moby bastard
who doesn't know anything you know
Tyrion Lannister a character who's so
awesome in slap Peter Dinklage will get
every good dwarf role until he dies or
Warwick Davis kills him and an Aerys
Targaryen a superhot queen obsessed with
her dragons she's out for vengeance
against the people who killed her family
the eventually one of these days
can we just fast-forward to that part
watch as these heroes struggle to end
the reign of King Justin Bieber leave a
face I like a pretty god if he doesn't
die this season I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
him myself
can hate that kid ride along on an
adventure where any lead character can
die whether you're Sean Bean Sean beans
wife Sean beans best friend Sean beans
son Sean beans daughter-in-law Sean
beans family dogs for Sean beans unborn
grandkid all men must die who are in any
way close to Sean Bean so begin the epic
journey so long and complicated we
really hope the Creator doesn't eat
himself to death before he's finished
writing it and settle in for a show with
so many monologues HBO both desperately
try to keep your attention by any boobs
necessary
[Music]
not that I'm complaining beam's starring
the 10 characters whose names you
actually remember and all these other
characters whose names you actually
don't remember like the sneaky guy
the sneaky bald guy Carl Drago those gay
dudes Lord friendzone grumpy old dad
that's the same person right
sand sand Santa Ron brand bran again Sam
not Sam's the fat one from Lord the
graves oh she's the one who had a demon
baby that's the guy to get his dick cut
off I don't remember her name but she's
super high OS Tyrians a hooker
girlfriend oh oh Hodor that's Hodor okay
now you just mess with me
no idea oh please Lissa Sasson that
guy's awesome not include No nope nope
nope don't know I got nothing yeah none
of these are ringing a bell go make up
your own names nerds Game of Thrones
it's kind of like a history test
but with dragons and beers if you put
any spoilers in the comments I'll kill
you
but to all my book bros R plus L equals
J you know what I'm talking about a
lannister always subscribes so click
that button now hey screen junkies want
to see me act stupid then click the box
above to see the epic drive through boys
prank the more times you share it the
more money we raised for charity winter
is coming
the Lannisters send their regards
standby for titanfall I'm a smelly
butt-head who likes to wear dresses and
I poo I like big butts in a can not lie
you other brothers can't deny the same
thing we do every night pinky
try to take over the world
[Music]